article came out from Washington
examiners saying only 17 percent of
black voters support defunding the
police their survey of black voters
conducted by the grion kff published on
Wednesday as thousand black adults who
say they are registered to vote for
their opinion on policing about half of
those polled 48 percent said they would
like to see police funding kept about
the same while 34 percent said they
wanted increased financial support just
17 percent responded that they support
decreasing the funding for the police
the poll also found out that three on
four black voters viewed criminal
justice and policing as a very important
factor in making their decision about
who to vote for including 77 percent of
Democrats and 68 percent of Republicans
the issue of crime was as important for
those who made under forty thousand
dollars per year as for those making
over ninety thousand dollars more
important interesting should be more
important under 40 than above 90.
because people the community you're
living in well yeah the community you're
living in The Police become more
valuable a lot of people who make more
money have access to private security
and all those perks but if you're making
forty thousand dollars a year and and
particularly by the way if you live in
an area where your Second Amendment
right isn't protected these people
aren't armed themselves these
law-abiding citizens so they rely
heavily on the police being active and
present and they don't have the money to
afford the private security that's some
of the issues that came up with the Paul
Pelosi story that I think you know
everyone ran with those arguments you
said by the way the they that ran with
the arguments about its q and on this
Hillary Clinton was on board name
profiles people were just asking like
hey where are the security cameras isn't
it odd that was there an alarm system
isn't it like some of the the stuff just
wasn't making sense and they were
questioning and of course you're not
allowed to question a narrative
sometimes you know the left will jump
back and say oh well you just you want
you want violence no no one wants
violence but some of the stuff just
didn't make sense and didn't add up with
that initial narrative that Adam was
mentioning about Q Anonymous you know
it's funny uh matter you know like the
story you're telling about like how
liberals in New York will put up a
sticker let's say yeah but like that's
not the reality that they'd actually
what they stand for in real life like
have you you know this reminds me of
it's like almost like the the cognitive
dissonance of like in in real life real
time Tyler see if you can pull this up
you ever seen this I think it was like
someone sitting in an airport on their
Apple laptop computer and with like a
sticker that's like capitalism sucks all
right socialism rules while they're
sitting there on their Apple laptop with
their Apple ear uh head uh eardrums or
ear Beats or whatever
okay with their Starbucks in their hand
with their McDonald's Egg McMuffin like
capitalism sucks it's like how unaware
of you of what you have going on in your
life to be preaching that but like
living something completely different
from what you're saying on your sticker
but you know where that comes from that
comes from Academia because these kids
learn in school they have a total
disconnect like you you go through
economics you go through all these
classes and you have no concept of what
these policies actually look like in the
real world so they're dissociated from
reality and it's like oh I'm gonna sit
here and oh wait a minute is this
something that emerged from capitalism
there's no thought process there so
they're just like the talking points the
sticker being accepted but they don't
actually process that what they're
advocating for would prevent them from
living the lifestyle that they actually
want to live well it's it's Martha's
Vineyard yeah how fast did they bring in
the National Guard two days for two what
happened it was a couple hundred
migrants right two days they brought in
the National Guard kicked those people
out the same people that have black
lives matter nobody
we're all immigrants nobody's illegal
Etc et cetera et cetera this has been
going on for 30 years or more right this
is the whole limousine liberal movement
right and I I separate that from I think
what really happened which was an
absolute
um not to be ironic but a crime what
happened is the people that are in the
inner cities in those areas living down
there trying to find a better job trying
to escape trying to get to the next rung
of a social ladder
you have to see what happened in a lot
of these cities to avoid engagements the
police reduced patrols from like 11 pm
to 6 a.m and so the people that were
living down there that were not drug
dealers they were living in
neighborhoods they could afford living
in neighborhoods they'd live for
generations and just trying to find
where do I go from here what's my next
step where's the jobs where's where
where's the thing and they're down there
and they're the victims of the crimes
and they're the victims of what's going
on down there and then the police
defunded or intimidated to the point
that they with the body cams and
everything they don't want engagements
they don't want to go down there and
Patrol because it's going to create an
engagement it's going to create an
engagement on film and the films can be
used in a narrative and so the people
that really lose here he says and that
it should be not surprising to anybody
to say that 17 of American
African-American or black voters
support defunding the police and the 83
percent of them are uh no I I need the
police and I need them to be down here
um and I think there's some cities like
Dallas that have shown you know
exemplary change and then you've got
places right now where would you have
ever thought Pat that the political
polling in Oregon would be what it is
right now instead of an election strange
why is that did maybe crime and economy
ever hit people so first thing if you
ever build a country and you're
competing say the war you know
Armageddon happens there's only a
million people left everyone's thinking
about where to put their kids and where
to raise their family the first thing a
mom thinks about is the s word it it's
security and safety if you can't provide
that in any City in any state in any
country you lose people period mom's
going to sit there and say listen man I
have one job the Natural Instinct of a
mom is to protect their kids you screw
with her you you have a Wrong Enemy you
cannot mess with moms and that's what
they do it's just not going to work out
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
thank you